Transcriber: Çise Ak
Gözden geçirme: Ali Eren Kayhan
Herkese iyi günler.
Umarım herkes kendisi için
faydalı bir gün geçirir.
Teşekkürler davet ettiğiniz için bu arada.
Şimdi.
Şimdi minik minik bir şey okuyarak
başlamak istiyorum izninizle.
Sonra bırakacağım telefonu, başka
olasılıkları hayal edin.
Farkı deneyin.
Ön yargılı fikirlerden kurtulun.
Ufkun ötesine bakın.
Yeni bir dünya keşfedin.
Hemen koyun.
Acaba bütün bu söylediklerim
hangi aktivitede yer alır?
Sanat yaparken bütün bu yeter her şey.
Sanat yaparken birebir yaşadıklarınız
esasında.
Çünkü bilmediğiniz bir şey
için yola çıkıyorsunuz.
Onu hayal ediyorsunuz.
Önünüze birçok problem çıkıyor.
O problemleri devamlı burada çıkan
problemler, çoğunlukla kendi yarattığımız
problemler, hayallerimizin
yarattığı problemler.
Ve o problemleri çözmek için yaratıcı
çözümler buluyorsunuz.
Bunu bulurken ne kullanıyoruz?
Ellerimizi, ayaklarımızı , vücudumuzu,
fiziğimizi, duygularımızı,
düşüncelerimizi, bütün tecrübelerimizi.
Sanatın en muhteşem yanı, kendimizi tam
kapasite kullandığımız bir an yaratıyor.
Ve bu an o kadar değerli ki.
Sanat için değerli değil
ama sizin için değerli.
Çünkü ilerde bu ufukta bilmediğiniz,
yolculukta ihtiyacınız olan bir çok şeyi
sanat yaparken geliştirdiğiniz
anlamına geliyor.
Çünkü büyük bir haksızlık var,
oradan onu söyleyeyim.
18 yaşında, 19 yaşında, gencecik,
kalbi aşkla dolu, sevdiklerine yönelik,
hayatı
bilmeyen, ilerde ne olacağını bilmeyen
gencecik insanlara hayatı boyunca
yapacağı meslekleri
seçtirmeye çalışıyoruz.
Bu çok büyük bir haksızlık.
Ben çevremde çok sayıda insan biliyorum.
Yaptığım mesleği sevmiyor ama yapmak
zorunda çok çok az insan biliyorum.
Yaptığım mesleği severek yapıyor.
Bu konuda çok şanslıyım.
Çünkü inanılmaz inanır, inanılmaz derece
zevkle yaptığım ve inanarak yaptığım bir
mesleğim var.
Çocuklarla, gençlerle sanat yapmak.
Ama bunun ötesinde o zevkle yapan, hani
tam ihtiyaçlarını bulmuş, o ufkun
ötesindeki mutlulukla yapacağı bir mesleği
bulmuş kişilerin de neredeyse
yüzde 99'u şans eseri bunu bulmuş oluyor.
Yani büyük bir piyango var
önümüzde esasında.
Bu geleceği öğrenmemiz ya da
bilmemiz mümkün değil.
Ama burada vereceğimiz kararlar da o
yürüyeceğimiz yol ve yaşayacağımız
süreçte en güzel şey
kendimizi geliştirmek.
Ben çok sonuna kadar inanıyorum ki sanat
bu anlamda inanılmaz şeyler veriyor.
Kendimizi geliştirmek için
ve o yaşayacağınız
yolun da esası minik bir kısa süreli
her sanat yaptığınızı
yaşınız kısa süreli denemesi.
Bilmediğiniz bir yola çıkıyorsunuz
her adımda gerekli çözümleri buluyorsunuz,
ilerliyorsunuz.
Sonucunda yaptığınızı beğenirseniz,
en güzeli. O zaman demek ki başarılı
bir süreç gerçekleşmiş oluyor.
Bir döngü tamamlanıyor.
Hiç bilmediğiniz bir şeyi hayal edip,
oturup onu yapıp,
yaptıktan sonra beğendiğiniz, o biten
başarılı döngünün sonucunda
herkes, yapan kişi, kendisini
başarılı hissetmeye başlıyor.
Bence bu iş çok önemli.
Çünkü gelecekte adımlar atarken özgüvenli
olmak, kendinin farkında olmak,
farklılığının farkında olmak, becerilerini
geliştirmiş olarak orada
olmak çok değerli.
Arkada bir resim var.
Gördüğünüz gibi sanata biraz
daha bağlamak istiyorum.
Sanatın ne olduğu üzerinden
gitmek istiyorum.
Çok hızlı bir şekilde vaktim.
Çünkü 2 saat ifadeler de tamam güzel.
Burada sanat nedir konusunda baya bir
eğitim almama rağmen Mardin'deki on bir
yaşındaki bir çocuktan muhteşem
bir cevap aldım.
Eşek herif diyorum.
Bütün kalbimle ve bütün sevgimle
eşek herif diyorum.
Her seferinde onu anıyorum.
Çünkü cevabın son kelimesi,
şey.
Hani sanat nedir diye soruyorum.
Cümle var bir iki cümle,
bir iki kelime oluşur.
Sonunda şeyh yani ne olduğunu
biz söylemiyor mu?
O kadar muhteşem bir cevap ki belli.
Ne dedi biliyor musunuz sanatın
ne olduğunu
cevaben? Canı gönülden yapılan şeydir.
Yani ne olduğunu söylemiyor ama nasıl
yapılması gerektiği konusunda inanılmaz
bir yol çiziyor.
Canı gönülden yapılması, canı gönülden
kelimesini eminim hepiniz duydunuz.
Çok kullanmıyoruz ama benim için sadece
artık sanatın tanımında
kullandığım bir kelime.
Çünkü içerisi o kadar çok
şey var ki ki bu.
Avrupa Birliği projesi yapıyorduk ve
projenin başında British Council vardı.
Yani dünyadaki İngilizcenin en
yüksek otoritesi değil mi?
Canı gönülden kelimesinin İngilizcede
karşılığı yok.
Tek kelime olarak kökünü ister.
Çünkü hem can var hem gönül var.
Her şey var.
Her şeyini vererek yaptığından bahsediyor.
Diliyorum ki hepiniz için canı gönülden
yapacağınız bir mesleğiniz olur.
Şimdi sanata geldiğinizde bu
“canı gönülden yapılan şeydir” durumunda.
Çocuklarla ve gençler.
Bu çok daha ki devamlı konuşuyorum.
“Her isteyen sanatçı olabilir mi?”
diye soruyorum.
Cevap üzücü.
Yüzde seksen beş civarı
çocuk “Olamaz.” diyor.
Çocuk derken on yedi yaşları da
kast ediyorum. On sekizlere kadar...
çocuğuz hepimiz. “Niye?” diyorum,
“Çünkü yetenekli olmak lazım.” diyor.
“Nasıl yani?” diyorum.
Hatta diyor ki “Doğuştan gelir.”
Yani, doğduktan sonra... Ben kızımın
doğumunda ne yazık ki bulunamadım.
Erken doğdu ama doğduğunda şöyle
bir şey bu oluyor bilmiyorum.
Doğuranlar varsa öğretmenlerimiz
arasından sorabiliriz.
Belki. Doğduktan sonra bir tane bir
şaplak geçiriyoruz, ağlatıyoruz.
Hoşgeldin Dünya’ya diyoruz.
Sonra kenarda bir profesör
var. “Dene bakalım.”
“Hm.. Tamam, doğuştan yetenekli.”
Popoya bir damga mı var?
Böyle bir durum yok. Kim karar verir,
doğuştan yetenekli olduğuna?
Şimdi orada yeteneğin ne olduğu
sorusu ortaya çıkıyor.
Onu da sordum çocuklara.
Cevap çocuklarda çünkü.
Bu sefer Gaziantep’te çıktı karşıma.
Öyle bir cevap verdi ki!
Hani, bazen bir durum olur ya.
Anne babamızı çok kızdırırız. Çok kızar.
“Tamam,tamam bir daha yapmayacağım.”diye
böyle bir
kenara çekiliriz ya, öyle bir durum oldu.
Hatta üçüncü gündeyiz Gaziantep’te.
“Devamlı bana çay ister misin?
diye soruyor.
Ben de çay sevmem. Teşekkürler,
almam,teşekkürler.
Ama bu hani saatte 3 defa filan oluyor.
Çocuk bu cevabı verdikten sonra yine
bütün sevgimle eşek herif diyorum.
Çünkü cevabın sonu şey.
O cevap verdikten sonra
dedim ki alayım çay.
Orada öyle bir travma yaşadım yani
çay içtim, içtikten sonra sevdim.
Öyle bir durum oldu.
Şekersiz içmeme rağmen.
Söylediği şey şuydu bir de
hareket de yaptı yani.
Bir de olayın verdiği cevabın fiziksel bir
karşılığı da var. Şöyle yaptı bana.
Bende olan başkasında olmayan şey...
Bende olan başkasında olmayan şey,
sizde var mı o?
Eğer bu 8 milyar civarı insanın yaşadığı
dünyada sizden bir tane daha yoksa.
Hepimizde başka kimsede
olmayan bir şey var.
Bu insan mucize dediğimiz şey her doğan
insanın farklı olarak doğması.
Sanat burada şu anlamda çok değerli.
Çünkü o her biri farklı olan, dünyada bir
tane daha olmayan, o insanların
sonuna kadar...
istedikleri şekilde çalışabilecekleri
sonsuz bir alan sunuyor neredeyse.
İstediği gibi bunun hatta sağlamasını
bile yapabilirim.
Şöyle bir sağlama yapıyorum.
Herkese aynı kağıdı verelim, herkese
aynı kalemi verelim.
Bütün dünyadaki, 8 milyardan bahsediyorum.
Herkesi aynı masaya ve
sandalyeye oturtalım.
Ikea herkese yetecek kadar yapar.
Ondan sonra deyin ki 5 dakikanızı var.
Ve konuyu da belirleyebilir... Diyelim ki
herkes balık çizecek.
Hatta onu da bir adım öteye götürelim.
Diyelim ki hani balık sizin vardı ya.
Şöyle bir tek çizgiyle şöyle balık.
Herkes bu şekilde balık çizecek diyelim.
8 milyar insan aynı masa sandalyede,
aynı kağıt, aynı kalem.
5 dakikada o balıktan çizdikten sonra iki
tane aynı balık çıkar mı sorusu var.
Çıkar mı çıkmaz.
Çıkarsa ilahi bir mucize
gerçekleşmiş olur.
Bunun sebebi de kağıtta değil, kaleminde
değil, masada değil, sandalye değil.
Bunun sebebi bizlerde. Farklı ve tek
olmamızda. Ve sanatın o kadar...
sınırlandırmamıza rağmen,o kadar geniş bir
alanda bizi o farklılığımız doyasıya
yaşayacağımız bir alan
bırakıyor olmasında.
Yetenek sınavı.
Şimdi yetenek nedir diye konuştuğumuzda
hani verdi ya çocuk o cevabı...
normalde esasında.
Birçoğunuz şaşırmış olabilir.
Çünkü yeteneğin karşılığı Türkiye'de ve
dünyanın birçok yerinde de böyle.
Esasında ufak yaşlarda başlar.
Neyin ne olduğunu siz benden daha
iyi biliyorsunuz esasında.
Gördüğü şeyi en çok benzeterek çizen
çocuk okulda yeteneklidir,
sınıfta yeteneklidir.
Bunu tahmin ediyorum.
Benzer tecrübeyi siz ilkokuldan
beri yaşıyorsunuz değil mi?
Biz yetişkinler böyle bir
kurgu yapıyoruz çünkü.
Ve,her bütün yetişkin adayı en azından
ben kendi adıma özür dilerim,
bundan dolayı.
Çünkü çok yanlış bir yönlendirme.
Gördüğümüzü çizerek
yetenek olsaydı zaten fotoğraf makinesi
çıktıktan sonra insanlar sanat yapmayı...
bırakmalıydı,değil mi?
Ama bırakmadılar.
Çünkü başka bir şey var orada.
Sanat o değil.
Hatta sanat nedir diye çok soruyorum.
Herkes yetişkin çocuk farketmez.
Şu ana kadar 50 binden fazla insana sormu-
şumdur yabancı ve Türkiyeli. Hiçkimse bana
şunu dedi gördüğü şeyi çok iyi benzeterek
yapmak sanattır demedi.
Kimse gibi herkes dediki duygular,
düşünceler bir şeyler aktarmak.
Hiç kimse onu söylemedi ama çocukların
önündeki en büyük duvar
gördüğünü en iyi çizerim.
Çocuğun yetenekli olup ki bu da özellikle
ilkokulda sınıf içerisinde
ki en önemli yıllar.
Sınıf geçen 30 kişilik
bir sınıfta bir-iki.
Düşünsenize 30 kişilik bir sınıfta her
hafta bir-iki kişi kendisini yetenekli
zannediyor, mutlu oluyor.
Ama acı kısmı 28 tane çocuk başarısız,
yeteneksiz ve
beceriksiz hissediyor kendisini.
Ve her hafta devamlı olarak yaklaşık 8
10 yıl belki de daha fazla sürüyor.
Ve bu bizlerin yarattığı çok yanlış bir
sistemin, sanatla bağlantılı bir sistemin,
bir kült, çok çok kötü bir yanı ,
çocukların özgüvenini biraz ezen ve
onları gelecekte farklı adımlar
atması konusunda tam da bu.
Hani ufka gitme yolunda esasında
önüne taş koyan bir yaklaşım.
O yüzden sanat yapın, yapın ki kendinizi
geliştirin, daha becerikli olun, daha
kıvrak zekalı olun, daha yaratıcı düşün.
Yaratıcı düşünmek de çok kolay.
Kendin gibi düşüneceksin.
Sadece bilgiye dayanmak zorunda değilsin.
Kendin oraya yaratıcı bir çözüm bulacaksın
ve sanat da zaten bu.
Hemen her sahneyi, yaptığım
işi o kadar kolay ki.
Kalem kağıda bu konu nereye gidecek?
Sağı mı, sola mı, aşağı mı, yukarı mı?
Hep karar veriyoruz.
Her an, her saniye ve doğal bir
şekilde karar veriyoruz.
Ve bütün bunun sonucunda da gerçekten
kendimizi geçtiğimiz bir süreç yaşıyoruz.
O anlamda sizi gerçekten tavsiye ediyorum
sanat yapmayı, tırnak içerisi güzel şeyler
yapmak için değil ama kendinizi
geliştirmek için yapın. Bunu instagramda
gördüğüm zaman çok beğendim.
Muhteşem hiçbir özelliği yok.
Muhteşem çünkü sevgiyle
yapıldığı çok belli.
O atın o güzel yüzü , o inanılmaz farklı
bacakları çok çok etkiledi beni.
Ama arkadaki... Bedava, üstüne
para verseniz almam.
Çünkü gerek yok.
Fotoğrafını çekelim gidip atıp. Niye
ona benzetmeye çalışayım ki?
Ama burada özel bir şey var.
Kendisinden bir şey katmış.
Bu yapamamakla ilgili değil.
Köşeli olabilir. Çünkü bu...
Bu arada arkada at yok, özür
dilerim, onu düzeltmen lazım.
Biz yetişkinler sanıyoruz ki
orada at var, at yok orada.
Birinin hayalindeki çizdiği at resmi var.
O at resmi olduğu zaman da köşeli de olur.
Tek bacağı incecik olur, öbür
bacak kalın da oulur.
Çünkü bak yapmış olmuş.
Bazen şey diyoruz ben Pembe
Filin dramı diyorum.
Bir tane çocuk resim yapıyor, pembe bir
fil yapıyor, kanatlar takıyor, götürüyor
öğretmenine ya da bir yetişkine
gösteriyor.
Yetişkinlerin genel tavrı nedir?
Pembe fil olur mu?
Filin kanatları olur mu?
Şimdi bu doğru bir cevap olabilir.
Ama ders eğer bir ders değilsek, eğer
ders fil anatomisi dersi ise kabul
ediyoruz o zaman doğru filmin anatomisine
göre orada evet kanat olmamalı ama öyle
bir dersimiz var mı? Yok herhalde
diye düşünüyorum.
Sanat dersi ise yaratıcı olduğumuzda
ufkumuzu genişlettiğimiz bir şeyse
kanatlı da olur, pembe da olur, yeşil
de olur diye düşünüyorum.
Bu arada olmaz diyoruz çocuğa,
karşımızda var yapmış.
Bu arada hadi çocuğun da
nasıl olmaz diyor.
Ben yapmışım zaten ediyor diye neye olmaz
diyor gibi düşünceleride var esasında.
Biz yetişkinler biraz hızlı büyüdüğümüz
zaman ve hayatın yorucu yanlarında
geçmişimizi ve çocukluğumuzu
herhalde unutuyoruz.
Unuttuğumuz için bence bu problemler
yaşandı diye düşünüyorum.
O yüzden sanat yapın, yaparken kendi
istediğiniz şekilde yapın.
Başkasına beğendirmek çabasına girmeyin.
Kendinizi tatmin edin.
Çünkü o sırada özgüven gelişir.
Beceriler gelişir. Hem zihinsel hem
fiziksel. Duygularınızla iletişim halinde
olursunuz ve bunun sonucunda da çıkan
iş gerçekten özel bir şeye dönüşür.
Birçoğumuz bununla ilgili şu anda.
Hani bize değilse çok geç gibi düşünüyor.
Hiçbir zaman geç değil.
Şu anda Türkiye’nin en önemli vefat etmiş
sanatçılarından bir tanesi...
demek durumundayım yazık ki.
Üzülerek söylüyorum. Burhan Doğançay var.
Türk sanat tarihinde önemli bir yeri var.
Eserlerini beğenirsiniz beğenmezsiniz,
o size ait bir şey.
Ama Burhan Doğançay'ın şöyle bir yanı var.
Birçoğunuz bilmiyor olabilir.
Taksim tarafında bir tane
minik bu müzesi var,
kendi kurduğu. Babası da ressam,
hatta asker bir ressammış .
Beraber eserlerini sergilendiği
bir müzesi var bu.
Bir şey daha söyleyeyim.
Dünyada Türkiye’deki en pahalı sanat
eseri, en yüksek fiyata satılmış kişi
aynı zamanda kendisi ve sanat eğitimi yok.
Hatta memurmuş Türkiye devletinde
çalışan bir memurmuş.
New York'a gittikten sonra orada memuriyet
hayatını New York'ta devam
ederken sanat yapmaya karar verip
memuriyeti de bırakıyor.
Hatta işini de bırakıp New York gibi o
dönemde de dünyanın sanat merkezi.
Ama sanattan para kazanmak çok zor.
Ona rağmen bırakıp beraber.
Eşi de var orada da, onu da destekliyor,
bırakıyor, sanat yapıyor.
O anlamda çok çok değerli bir şey
insanların verdiği kararları
takip edebilmesi.
O da bunu yapmış ve şu anda Türkiye sanat
tarihinde önemli bir yeri olan çok özel
bir sanatçıya dönüşmüş.
Lütfen ama lütfen sizi destekleyen
insanları dinleyin ama önünüze taş koyan
insanlara da onları dinleyeceksiniz.
Yapacak şeyi kulak kapatın demiyorum
tabii ki dinleyin
ama değerlendirin lütfen.
Bu konuda size sanat yapmanız anlamında
yeniden yüreklendirmek istiyorum.
Bu tamamen yanlış olduğunu
düşündüğüm bir yaklaşım.
Çünkü güzel sanatlara girerken
üniversitelerde ve liselerde. Böyle bir
sınav yapıyorlar. ‘Gördüğünü
nasıl benzeterek çiziyorsun’ sınavı.
sonra alıyorlar.
Bu kötü bir şey değil bu arada. Gördüğünü,
benzettiğini çizmek kesinlikle kötü değil.
Şunu belirtiyor. Ellerine hakim misin?
Ama herkes yapabilir,
yetenekle ilgili değil.
Kapatırken şunu söylemek istiyorum.
Lütfen, lütfen ama lütfen unutmayın.
Bende olan başkasında olmayan şey.
En güzeli hepinizde var.
Sevgiyle kalın.
Kolay gelsin.